in fur in Wow that would start over yeah
in for research purposes no in for
research purposes before we search
correction here my life is over
having you in for research purposes News
submitted by pizza butter jkp reference
Pizza butter all we said pizza butter
sounds familiar we created it if it
wasn't just make oil thing Pizza butter
it sounds familiar
I don't memorize that's what it was we
did it but seriously you should have
bent that that's what does someone in
Jake if he said me too I think I've said
it to you but we do improv stuff so I
don't remember what we say yeah but
Pizza Pizza flavored stuff never tastes
like pizza you ever had pizza flavored
Pringles or chips or anything in there
because it never tastes like what it
tastes good it's never there though then
call it Regan Oh tomato butter I don't
care those chips are always so
unsatisfying it's like it's like this
will taste like nachos and I'm like oh
yeah oh I thought you fall for it every
time I do every new flavor I fall for it
oh my goo this one's chicken and waffle
candles are on point though they always
smell like the thing they say I wish you
could eat the candles [ __ ] Willy
Wonka here alright it's not gonna taste
like whitefish snozzberries don't taste
like snozzberries a woman describes her
experience with trying six different
ways to reach an orgasm 6y1 okay um
clitoral g-spot butt butt hole titty
orgasm oh yeah and what I've heard is
the biggest thing the same spot it just
gets hit from different angles well then
I would say I would count that is
through oh that's true so I heard the
biggest female orgasm it's not a joke
it's real
[Applause]
no I put it out put it out the fire I
know I've heard that the biggest female
orgasm happens through the mouth
actually it's a medical trip you would
have nailed the verbage it would have
been funnier again they come real hard
old timey camera you mean from kisi yeah
look you see this author here she's a
vice author her name is Ali and she's
just saying that not all women orgasm
the same way you don't have to tell me
that sister you mean we're not all equal
yeah she's saying that depending on who
you speak to like there could be like a
wide range of how many different orgasms
women can reach but right here for today
we're just gonna be talking about six
ways there's six out of 85 or something
see that's why if a guy thinks he knows
because his last girlfriend like he
could you know do it really good every
time like they still need to be trained
like on you because you're different how
did you how did you turn me I'm just
like go lower or go higher
oh I'm saying like sometimes girls like
different things on their body totally
you said go higher go higher go higher
right go higher higher all the way up to
the mouth it's alright it's every time
you're so funny let's see how much sexy
cause oh yeah apparently there's between
two to twelve types of female orgasms
well [ __ ] just bait can barely come once
this is Ali okay that's just a penknife
you mean twelve different types of doing
this through your body she'll talk about
it don't you wanna try not figure out
there's 12 different ways of doing it
you'll never figure out how it's you
reach or even what is there to not
understand sound like you can't like you
just start talking about them you keep
talking about the number but we don't
really go into any of they've been
trying to go into me oh just get to it
already
yeah
how come I wake up from a dream without
anyone touching me and I orgasms you're
awesome
see that's 101 - is it see I got a point
that's one of them it's a wet dream I
never that one the first one is clitoral
so the clitoris is applied mainly by the
condole nerve the vagina mainly by the
pelvic nerve and the cervix mainly by
the hypogastric pelvic and badges nerves
while stimulating each of these regions
can by itself produce orgasms the
combined simulation of all three regions
which is a blended orgasm has an
additive effect so this is all said by
dr. Beverly are you not doing all of
these to me I know I'm to a clitoral
cervical was a third one
Oh vagina ain't no plastic cervical one
what the and tonsil now we're just his
body parts like like space rocks and
like moons and planets and [ __ ] we're
like if the doctor who finds it gets the
name and after himself like was there a
doctor named vulva and like you know my
clitoris I think most body parts are
Latin words because it's kind of like a
secret language for people that were
educated yeah you know that know
everyone knew that and also did the guy
that named the Volvo like even know
about the vulva cuz like well because
his last name was that that's why I'm
saying they like they put their stamp on
the [ __ ] that they make your car sounds
like a vagina name okay she got her
boyfriend to help her through all of
these experiments
so here's her boyfriend oh he looks so
depressed did she faked it for him
though you know what I'm saying it was
all for research purposes yeah like
honey we got a [ __ ] I was like oh you
got it you totally got that one that was
she said that the clitoral was not the
best orgasm but doggystyle is her
favorite position because she can touch
herself while she's getting vaginal
penetration so that's still a clitoral
orgasm because yes the stimuli but now
she's combining combining well what is
this is this in like the Daily Mail no
it was the Vice I just think I just
loved unideal her parents it's like hey
mom and dad we're advice I'm a
journalist my research you know we had
an article it's on the Internet it went
viral
I've heard of this
for but I feel like it's so
uncomfortable to do that while that's
happening like it you need a shoulder to
prop you up right all right like usually
got you to front like this it's already
moving your clitoris you know and then
just you have to I don't know it's too
much work the second type of orgasm in
Foley's spot please explain to him where
it is you had to come here that's how it
works I'm ready for the next video okay
so the g-spot is found at the anterior
wall of the vagina along the urethra and
either 12 o'clock position with the
woman lying on her back stimulating
deep-lying tissue that surrounds the
urethra by pressing against the internal
vaginal surface with a come here motion
we getting this was most likely to
produce orgasm science of orgasm so for
her this area is more sensitive than
others but not enough to make her orgasm
only when she stimulates her clitoris
but that just turns into a blender can I
just say though that she might have not
felt it with that guy because but
boyfriend shake yeah different shapes
because I think that like if you have a
girthier dick like it could hit the
g-spot mmm easier than other dicks that
maybe aren't so girthy and then you're
like oh I never knew this was possible
so for research yes - yes you should
find a more choked looking dick or
something weird in stumpy just like
honey I got a do it research sort of my
job as a journalist the third one and
the cervical orgasm you're in over the
service yes that sounds deep all the way
in the back it is deep that sounds like
some baby stuff
sounds like out of my range bless you to
reach a yes you fine let me tell you
that name Spica yeah it says here that
the couple should use a position in
which there's deep penetration of the
penis one position is with the woman
lying on her back with their legs
elevated up around the man's back or
neck picture it picture us tip no sorry
I don't want to you why would you do
yeah you already have me in the position
that's really nice this random woman
here is penetrated so dependent raishin
is more likely if the this random woman
my tattoos on the toward the body on my
poor being a pillow under the woman's
lower back can also allow deep
stimulation this is all according to her
just find a guy with a bigger dick just
son I wouldn't recommend the pillow
thing I would put a towel over there cuz
that [ __ ] gets soaked it and you don't
want to sleep it's a natural thing that
happens in it so forgiveness scored
every time right but no so for Ally
particular she said that instead of
feeling pressure she felt too much
pressure on her cervix and she wasn't
really able to achieve Nikki doesn't
like Jesus like I didn't know while
she's doing this apparently in a study
out of 132 women she should just say I
don't know how to take a dick [ __ ] dude
this is my chick right here but going
into descriptions like yeah yeah and
she's like I didn't really like it that
much cuz it too much pressure like what
yeah good for you good for you stick up
for yourself in this because in a study
out of 132 women only 46% orgasm to
cervical stimulation it was 86% vaginal
in 98 did they all had the same dick see
that's why you can't do a group site a
study like that there has to be the same
dick [ __ ] all 140 of them there's too
many variables in this study I have a
great life alright the fourth way is a
urethral organic urethral orgasm okay
it's like what the teeny tiny dings oh
yeah what is that
so here it says uh theoretically if you
stimulate the small area of sensitive
tissue around the urethral opening that
lies between your vagina and clitoris
you're probably stimulating your
clitoris too which is what leads to
orgasm I'm learning too much I still
feel like that's the same as a clitoris
yeah cuz they're saying that this
because your [ __ ] is mostly internal
yeah it's like different forms of looks
like the backside of your coat is like
up signs outside sideways upside down
side side it's like different clitoris
stimulation because no matter what it's
like the prerequisite like wall you're
getting the g-spot you need the clitoris
one or like it's kind of like that has
to always happen no I got back in health
class dude this ruins the mystery for me
it does no guy should know that their
dicks not gonna hit all the spots yeah
they're gonna hit like one spot maybe
two spots but you're not there's a lot
of spots that you could hit that's the
good news your hands men hit one you can
write another one no it's not just your
dick come on Casey fire a vibrator
holy [ __ ] Casey you have two hands yeah
bro come on come on Casey like all the
cameras Casey me I'm not allowed to cuz
I got calluses all right so she said
that it took a while to get used to it
the whole like urethral stimulation and
she only orgasm when she stopped
thinking about the placement and she
just relaxed so she's skeptical whether
it really was a urethral orgasm or if it
was just a feeling even though relation
yes it was a brain workout just too much
in her brain we're gonna know it's like
if your brain is somewhere else you will
not achieve it or laundry undone yeah
it's true all right think about the
laundry probably thinking about but
about what you're what you're making for
dinner that night
yeah probably thinking about you're
doing the dishes yeah yeah yeah cut it
all right right right hey hey hey you
raced that nope am i speaking for all
women I know oh hey yeah well you can
tell them who did the dishes in the
laundry the other day oh did he do them
though I feel betrayed I feel betrayed
by you we have trust all right so the
fifth
orgasm is the sleep orgasm which you
mentioned and so it doesn't involve
speaking it's the only way she can come
guys she has to go to sleep
the areas of the brain that get
activated during physical contact can
also get activated during sleep and from
intense mental focus it triggers the
same physiological responses that we
experience during waking orgasm that's
like meditation sex I was having a dream
about you nothing
well good but we had to test out all
these different types of condoms and
that's what happened in the dream alley
in order to get herself mentally
prepared she watched his British soap
opera called EastEnders and it featured
him too
it features an incredibly erotic they
wouldn't dream about and so she dreamt
about it yeah so she went to sleep horny
that's the whole point she's trying to
mentally prepare yourself to be horny
she ended up showering with her
boyfriend and then she went asleep
sexually frustrated three hours later
she wakes up to orgasming for me yeah
right she put that just to say that she
did it I like that's you don't plan that
she said that for her she already
orgasms in her sleep about once a month
okay for heard something okay fires up
Pride and Prejudice goes the bed and she
comes like what the [ __ ] depressing ass
yeah why does every photo have her do it
that lips she wants make her face look
skinny like all these photos are kind of
like a blog post type of thing like
she's telling a story I don't know why
duck lips I just remember that Nikki
said she can't take it it's mental
orgasm so imaginary orgasms are things
that women are capable of experiencing
Wow
yeah yeah I thought I thought myself
vintage but I was high so oh do you
thought yourself into or guys yeah wow
that's crazy girls are powerful to the
mind is so powerful it's like no girls
oh it's like when you're acting and you
like remember the it's like a
substitution that's like where you can
remember what it feels like to have an
orgasm so it feels like you're having it
yep yep yep well don't do it right now
Jesus Christ all natural method actors
yeah well for Allie here those she
watched porn for 40 minutes
she felt slightly aroused but she
couldn't reach an orgasm just by visual
she watched like a whole movie I was
watching this strange sex documentary
thing and there's like a group thing
where it's called thinking off and they
actually have class
we're like people are lying in a circle
and you're all like this and like the
teacher guides you into orgasm by cool
yeah and like people are just you're not
even touching yourself or anything and
like people are just like having orgasm
and they say that like it lasts longer
than a regular orgasm guys two guys just
coming away right guys the Coens guys
sultry smooth voice does that come for
me now I want you to come for me like
it's Morgan Freeman in there they even
had like hypnosis orgasms and [ __ ] like
I'm not [ __ ] with that like and then
yet they interview the people or the
people like cattle I don't even have
regular orgasms anymore at all I just
thinking off is so much better that's
all I do is it's just like thinking of
oh that's like when people are plugged
into the matrix in the getting shot yeah
[Laughter]
right
jerk of the [ __ ] things of they're
holding for no reason yeah oh you know
how messy would be if it was all guys in
that room
[Music]